[Music]
welcome to winners on a Wednesday I'm
Samuel Leeds and this week I have the
pleasure the joy the honor the outburst
of bringing onto the show the amazing
and mother
hello you know what you are an
incredible human being and thank you -
please tell your back man what is it
that you did when we first met I was an
S you were a lonely man you had four
babies all under the age of four and you
were working like crazy long hours we
met and within four weeks what happened
I was financially free financially three
or four weeks that is just incredible so
let's hear the story that so tell me
tell me tell me what happened how did
you end up at the crash course from
being a nurse based in Newcastle
Newcastle Newcastle nurse ends up
financially free tells the story I was
looking for something to supplement my
income when I found out I was pregnant
with twins yeah I mean they're into the
more money here so I was open to
something but I just didn't know what it
was and last October we got my husband's
pension statement for what the forecast
when you retire at 65 and it was less
than 100 pounds a month and that was
something he'd been pin in it for 20
years
and we were like that's it okay we
definitely definitely do something here
and then last October out of the blue
exactly what happened when I thought I
wanted to be a nurse I just woke up one
day and wanted to be a property investor
Wow so you just had the urge a property
investor and I know nothing whatsoever
full-time nurse your husband's pension
is rubbish you both working crazy hours
you've got four kids yes I had them in
the joon-young kids
No so you're a biscuit so then you want
to be a property investor you've got no
money so what happened ask then stop
little kid on YouTube yeah annal to a
number of people and then I came across
Samuel eats the legend and you stuck out
just like - I just liked yo energy your
spirit the way you explain things on the
YouTube videos
it was brilliant well it just come on
the crash course and that would be that
yeah I remember coming in and feeling
quite nervous and I don't know what
would happen or yellow would anybody
speak to me what was what would happen
and I just remember back him up on the
first day and said could I shake your
hand because I wanted to thank you for
changing my life and I thought that
would be it
because I was then on the I was already
on my way I came to the crash cross the
end of February and I'd already
remortgaged the house to become a
property investor and how to deals gone
through and then we went through the two
days it was brilliant
out you got really yeah well you told us
not to use our phones so we have them
switched off and then Russell kept
pinging a message from Russell kept ping
and come and see me at the side of the
room come and see me at the cellar and
I'm thinking I'm not supposed to be
looking at my phone what am I gonna do
here and then I went in the break and I
went to see Russell at the side of the
room and he wanted me to join the
Academy and then you came over because
your
I know you're quite a shy person or at
least at least you say so
but you already did the crash course do
with this bubbly northern lady who was
you know really getting into it
and we really like Jim we knew that you
an action taker because you'd already
refinanced your house and you've got a
couple of deals on the table and we
thought you know what we will need to
support you we need to see the deal yeah
this is going to be a journey together I
had some big plans for you so so that's
why we approached you about the property
investors Academy yes would you join
which I know well I wasn't ready at that
point you're joining the Academy because
I've got I'd literally bought two houses
with that Wendy that I've got and there
was not there was no more money to pay
for the Academy so I'm paying for mine
on installment we source of the idiom
that was that was really precious and we
knew that we could work with you and you
could be successful so we work something
out right yeah which is cool okay so you
join the Academy at the back of the
crash course you've got those two deals
going through chalice what happened next
because it's quite a story
it's been quite the journey how's the
land use it again lots of things you had
dinner with robert kiyosaki
I have yes have helped us with that
Uganda Africa projects you're now not
working anymore no when did you when did
you last work as a nurse 15:38 world
2010 18 this year so you literally went
from so Mathieu I met you in Manchester
at the end of February at the crash
course so February joined the Academy on
the 19th of March yeah officially yeah
there were really good deals
well one deal fell through yeah yes
these things happen so one dia fell
through but I was still financially free
off one deal
that's incredible because the thing is
and although that day wasn't making you
like houses into houses a month it was
enough to replace your income it was and
that was life-changing
because they invented the pressure off
of roughly eight hundred pounds eight
hundred pounds which might not sound
like a massive amount of money to some
people but that was enough for you to
then do you want that was enough for me
to stop working yeah because the
definition of financial freedom is not
having loads of money having a private
jet the definition of financial freedom
is when your passive income my own games
apparent is enough to cover your living
expenses yes and that replaced your
income as a nurse which is insane ridic
but you were working so hard as a nurse
so okay
so you quit working I know technically
you're a subcontractor yes so I went
back to work after maternity two days a
week so that's why I replaced my income
I'm on the nurse Bank and it's up to me
whether I go to work or I don't go away
I don't need work since April so what
are you doing with those databases 24/7
property investing 24/7 a property
investor high-five that's so cool yes
you've had me all around the world corn
will Barcelona Uganda South Africa
Wolverhampton
[Music]
incredible journey what out what are the
deals have you done how are you making
more money now well have bought yes I
put a couple of HMOs and they haven't
all completed and I came along to one of
your courses and two deals felt earlier
on the same day and you were like we
have this cool shed this scheduled about
but the same day that you were supposed
to be on camera you just have two deals
fall through yes and you were like pull
your hair out you're really upset about
it and you just said look can we not do
the interview so we checked your date
but what happened today
yes I was all very focused and looked at
the money I had left him a pot because
obviously when you lose deals you lose
the new legal phrase you're losin ya
mortgage broker fees and everything else
that you've paid
looked at what I had left refocused with
myself in that very same week I managed
to secure two rent to rent serviced
accommodation deals fantastic and how
much money are they expected to be
generating now could be two thousand
each a month
crawfish if they're fully let worst-case
0 to 2000 and in anything in between
thousand one thousand you've got two of
them so you'll probably be making two
three four thousand pounds a month or
two deals we've serviced accommodation
you never know for sure because it just
depends on the bookings that come in but
then money tends to be very very high
that's awesome
amazing tensely of about some of the
trips that we've done then all over the
world well we have been to Barcelona
doing some teaching there and we were
staying at the W Hotel oh yes infinity
pools Yap tales of the bar you've got us
a private chef you got us yeah who had a
very heavy-handed Wayne Knight Yap to
Barcelona food drink training Beach
invincabels
Uganda
you can't you can't do it from the
minute you announced it I think it may
be March you announced it was gonna be a
competition for one person to win I
wanted that holiday and I wanted that
experience and I just continued working
as I was working and got it I was
[Music]
working we even had you speaking yes
speaking at the the workshops all we're
doing assessing the projects going to
all the different African villages
sleeping in the books yes and then
afterwards we went to you I didn't go
because sadly which you didn't notice me
it was horrific
yeah that accident was just oh yes tell
us about meeting the robber queues okay
he's a lot taller than I thought in
Pearce than he used to
yeah yeah this is tall so my husband as
tall as you his front and it was really
good we had one of the best tables we
had three of them in speakers on our
table plus Robert Kiyosaki and we had a
dinner with him and you could ask him
anything you wanted he's very
approachable full evening where you can
pick his brain yeah I mean you must be
pinching yourself a little bit it's real
you just can't believe that you're
sitting there yeah Rebecca Esaki having
dinner I mean go from working as a nurse
crazy working crazy hours to then travel
in the world having
robert kiyosaki I mean how does that
feel amazing yeah absolutely love s and
it's all coming to resolve your hard
work and the reason we sent you off to
those fancy places was because you won
the competition and we thought that you
were the most diligent hard worker
tell us a little about the ant story
doesn't know that something has been
really pivoted in your thinking ah yes
the Ann story you tell us the story on
the crash course about video was like
you're like to watch about ants on
YouTube and you watch one particular one
where the ant builds a bridge and they
all just fling myself towards this open
space to build a bridge and then they
all cross at the growth they go through
it round it across it anything to reach
the other side which is the goal and
that's what I do
it's not easy property investing is not
easy and there's lots of Hoops and
obstacles to get through around across
but I just keep at it
[Music]
he wasn't on board at all at the
beginning nor no he probably thought I
was really crazy or just slightly crazy
yeah yes yeah
because it's a big financial commitment
to refinance the house I just give him
all the positives about this and he knew
I really really wanted to do it we
agreed yeah you just grind grind and
what men don't like everything oh he's
all for it like at first it was HMOs Oh
shouldn't do that we shouldn't do that
and then now it's like instead of doing
the service accommodation she would get
another HR o C's it works
for yeah fantastic so what are we the
biggest learning points view up in the
biggest lessons disciplinary
disappointment definitely yeah
definitely and take action yeah you can
come along to the teachers you can come
along the crash course but if unless you
do something with that knowledge yeah
it's not worth having brilliant
absolutely brilliant
what would you say with really
approachable friendly kind generous I
mean how's it changed your life it's
totally life changing when I'm
financially free my neck schools to get
my husband financially free before my
first years upon the Academy and then
ultimately financially free within the
second year I can just go yeah this is
you last when I was in Uganda and I put
one of the accommodations the first
night and then we met on the 18th was
terrible
[Music]
booked on the crash course immediately
don't hesitate do it thank you so much
for watching the video
that is the reason why I'm doing this
your success is my oxygen every single
week we've got people becoming
financially free if you'd like to see
more success students you can do that
right here but what I'd really suggest
is why don't you come and join us at the
property investors crash course come on
on my guest completely free and all
personally be there for two days to help
you get started you can see what happens
right here what you'll notice is all of
these stories they all start at the
crash course so come along my guests
can't wait to see you there peace out